pourquoi dit-on rouler dans la farine
avec ces deux mots rouler et farine dans
la même expression ça sent l'arnaqué à
lui seul le mort où les employés ici au
sens figuré signifie déjà trompé du p
mais la farine de l'expression en
rajoute une couche si je puis dire au
xvième siècle déjà on associe la farine
à l'idée de mal faire le mauvais coup à
l'époque on dit que des choses ou des
personnes qui ne valent rien qu'elles
sont de même farine on dirait
aujourd'hui qu'elles ne valent pas mieux
l'une que l'autre en plus la farine fut
pendant longtemps le symbole du faux
semblant de l'artifice au théâtre au
xviie siècle quand les comédiens sont
sur scène ils ont souvent le visage
fardé de farine quand il ne porte pas de
masque bref quand il y à rouler et
farine dans la même expression sa son
arnaque